there may be a slight argument about how
you pronounce the name of element 117 I
would pronounce it 10 the scene like
iodine and chlorine but some people in
America say chlorine and iodine but my
feeling is that everybody will say
tennis scene because it sounds just like
the state of Tennessee
whereas tennis sign doesn't the reason
why it was called Tennyson is because
Tennessee is the home of the Oak Ridge
National Laboratory where the berkelium
that was used to make the element to
synthesize it the heavy target was made
out of berkelium and the berkelium
sample was prepared in Oak Ridge then as
before we accelerate a light atom
calcium 48 a very expensive isotope of
calcium into the book helium and make
element 117 Tennessee now I think that
the interesting things about Tennyson is
to speculate about the chemistry the
first thing is that you could wonder
about its color if you could get a large
lump of tender seen if you'll go down
group 17 fluorine is almost colorless
slightly green and then as you go to
bromine is red iodine is a dark purple
color nobody knows what astatine looks
like and it's possible that Tennessean
might be a black gas which would itself
be really quite exciting now
unfortunately the way these experiments
are done is that although you would
expect Tennessee and being a halogen to
exist as two atoms Tennyson - just like
CL - you only make one atom at a time so
it's like some rare species of animal
there's just one in the zoo and you
can't find a mate so we'll never know
what Tennessee - looks like because we
can never get two atoms at the same time
I would predict that
menacing to would have a very weak bond
possibly the weakest bond between two
atoms of the same type that actually
bond together for example helium doesn't
bond to anything but it would be a very
very weak bond the other thing which is
interesting is to have a flight of fancy
imagine what some of the compounds would
be like and the one I would really like
to see is francium tennis I'd a bit like
sodium chloride but with francium the
element which loses an electron most
easily from the alkali metals and
telecine and I would predict that
francium tennis I'd would form crystals
which are really quite flexible if you
take caesium iodide higher up the
periodic table you can bend crystals of
cesium iodide without breaking them you
could probably make Springs out of
France in tennis I'd but it's so
radioactive that you would be got by the
radioactivity long before you make the
spring
and there we have nearly two inches
maybe of liquid fur and you can go right
up that's there's no problem with that
you want to just clear a bit of
condensation off there yeah I'm really
surprised I thought it would be pale
green and it's really quite dark yellow
if I'd been shown it I would have said
it was liquid chlorine I never seen
liquid chlorine either quite through
that I have been as for insectary giving
quite a few of my notes and things to
Keith to put in the archives so there
will be at least some trace of me even
if you can't read my emails